it's Matthew Martin from details of our
backstage at the London show he was all
about playing with the proportion this
season it would be like more of a sort
of bubbly voluminous rounder top with a
really really skinny trouser he gave her
really interesting silhouette is still
masculine but just something different
that you're not expecting he's really
known for his innovation with design and
there's some really cool things here
there's some beautiful skunk furs on
some of the shirting that were actually
died it gave it sort of like a sheen
which is very cool a lot of the shirts
were striped and you know one of the
cool things he did was he actually took
these extra pieces and glued them on so
it added to the stripe effect which is
definitely an innovative touch you know
the cool thing is if you look at all
these pieces and you see it in the show
and you think oh my god that looks like
so innovative and it's so fashion
forward but you know if you take the
pieces on their own they're really easy
to incorporate stuff we already have
like all the gorgeous jackets all the
even the sweatshirt tops even the really
skinny trousers everything here works
you have to find the pieces that you
think work the best for you for more
videos from Snowy parents check out
details calm and if you haven't already
follow me on instagram and twitter at
detail